welcome to this video and here we go
again Yardbird yacht brought in the
house k we going to play Queens Indian
now I have looked at this recently a bit
with them with white so let's give it a
go with black that's an interesting line
I'm not sure maybe LeBron has played
this himself with black that's very much
possible it would be a long his we
probably suit his taste I don't know
interesting non-standard position yeah
between b8 ideas to play Bishop d6 and
Bishop I'm control the dark squares here
I don't mind him to take not sure about
this but I won't start to think about
that now ok Bishop g5 was the idea so
that after f4 I can take take e4 but g7
hangs ok
okay i still can play that f4 takes
Queen takes Bishop before I'm attacking
the rook first interesting position
maybe you can still play it therefore
Bishop takes Queen takes be should be
for castles or so that that might be
possible giving away this point okay it
did not go for that its cage 60 here I
thought listen I g4 nice now let's let
them know him a little bit Bishop deform
or is this just a useless kind of
demonstration let's say yeah let's let's
do that looks it looks kind of in the
spirit of that line and now 95 I was
thinking or f5 maybe even f5f 395 is
definitely nice but f5 it's not quite
clear what I'm doing if you just castles
on awesome okay let's go back now a 5.4
Bishop tikz form interesting interesting
way of playing it look strong though
what does white do now be sure before is
a pretty big threat okay yeah i was
thinking queen bee seven maybe just
keeping things going there on the
diagonal Bishop takes Queen takes is not
so convincing should Bishop takes Queen
takes Bishop takes Queen takes I can't
play there's nothing particularly wrong
with that we should be form f 3 i'm not
sure maybe has compensation there if i
take before Knight takes Queen B seven
as this isn't this good and then
96 loses the Queen okay so much for that
and if I go queen be 7f for i have f
check c44 III yeah complicated and now
it very interesting yeah that's one of
the more exciting lines in the Queen's
in ian's the Queen's Indian sometimes
can get a bit a bit down on a bit stale
this opening but yeah not this slide
this is looking a lot like I know a
sharp Sicilian or so oh it's a tricky
position forward f4 Fe for every five
III that looks really good for black
okay let's not beat around the bush here
take you any way I accept some funny
ideas wish of age five check then I have
g6 I think just g6 now this champion
check this check ooh ah ooh I did not
see that one oh yes okay so not king of
eight I have to go here Oh funny i did
not see the check at all huh cool okay
so if i take bishop take with the bishop
does he have any check or whatever no
one taking this and I don't like the
idea to take here and what I want to
check III but then we'll get one but if
i take here i have got to two things I I
have to check here
wow I totally did not see that he can
play this Queen g6 check great job if I
if I would have castle day it would be
great yeah it would be a great position
I think because the bishops are really
strong here but without castling in my
king kind of hanging around in the
middle of the board it looks very
strange yeah what what am I going to do
probably have to play the Qing er I got
night he got the night check nice good
night b5 him I came but don't give if
you can check here what is the the
essence I should get a firefight that
would be helpful maybe I can get you
five Queen g7 rupee eight rook f8 maybe
that's that's the big big big problem
now that I think of it yeah that's the
big issue now he has rook evade now that
was stupid them they were badly plate I
just played badly I should have
calculated this rookie of a tandem it's
over oops it's not doing that yeah maybe
maybe it's also good but Luke f8 was I
think just winning
hmm okay
yeah that's also not not exactly easy
I'll take have really five for heaven's
sake that's the big problem no moose wow
what a shame it was that was such an
interesting position a Quincy cream g6
check how I probably missed something
there but be I really think that this
should should have been really good for
black boots I don't know maybe this f5
stuff and III was a bit bit too much
yeah I don't know the night be five
isn't 95 winning also yes my rook here
my rookie in the corner by pork okay
maybe if he has to trade Queens I'm kind
of alive still lost but still in the
game somehow yeah for Luke see one I was
thinking I have trapped some check but
it's just rip the 3 end and that's it
right check no no okay come on that's
that's resins black resins um pin so
isn't this good yeah i don't i don't
really believe that for what more this
going back end stuff f5 here queen bee
7f for hmm yeah so I really overlooked
that he has this check on g6 ah so what
is good then yeah just 94-97 is good
with this big pressure yeah I Queen g6 I
simply did not see check check here here
and here and now now I'm worse I'm just
were sium Bishop before is better though
here but ok yeah I could have played um
rook f8 I think this was just winning I
didn't didn't see any move then yeah
plus form
but ok it's not mattering he's he's he's
winning anyway my King has just just far
too far too exposed yeah i was
completely overlooking Queen g6 yeah I
have to move the night back like him and
just keep the pressure this it is quite
a bit of pressure that that white has to
it has to experience here i will tell
wind upon him it's not completely clear
I let's say I don't know maybe castling
I take and he goes out of the age file
for this and this is not completely
clear this position and because there
are some some tricks maybe my bishop on
the fourth kind of kind of loose but
well if i go to you five or what is he
doing I don't know what exactly geforce
oh yeah this will still be a mess in the
Blitz game objectively speaking blackest
is better here but tricky tricky
stricken position yeah Jay I'm basically
I'm probably probably toast the
compounds to play differently maybe I
should have done that grab the grab the
rook and that is actually much better
it's much better in comparison it didn't
feel right to me to give up my strong
Bishop there on deform but the big issue
is i get in King to c7 and Bishop
probably bag and this is pretty safe
actually he has no night to attack me
with 95 check or something and how is he
going to ever get to my king there
that's interesting computer gives equal
I don't know but I know if it is really
equal but this this is very safe I'm a
king a safe yeah
that's much better actually should have
done that yeah I don't know anything can
happen but this is a much better
defensive set up in comparison okay well
thanks for watching